what if all we can do is think how scary
a problem is there's so much fear in it
that it it's almost Untouchable we can't
deal with it then we're not ready to
face it and that's okay and there's
there's
some some prep work to be done within
ourselves and that's okay it's most
important to know where we are not to
fight all our monsters at
once and that goes back to sort of what
you said the intention you want to set
an intention for the coaching and if I'm
picking too many things
yeah if there's something that a client
really would like to do but there are
there's too much fear around it that's
not our
step our work is to take steps that are
super manageable and digestable and
actionable which builds the muscle for
us to get to that big scary thing
because as we walk closer to it that
mountain becomes more of a mole
hill how does an artist avoid negative
thinking and and spiraling you know
things are usually very extreme to
artists and so when things are going
great then we don't need to worry about
it but when things inevitably shift uh
we can spiral down I'm like how do any
of us avoid that oh
man it's it takes time and
practice to be able to catch ourselves
in the spiral I mean that's what
partnering with a coach is mainly for is
to bring us away from that the spiral
that's going to happen I think there's I
think the first step is acceptance this
is how the brain works this is how
humans are and there will be times when
something's going to set me off and I'm
am just going to spiral I accept that
that's part of my experience okay what
can I do about
it I accept that I'm going to be in a
state like this one day and what we can
do about it is start to become
interested more interested in what what
we actually want to be focused on where
we actually want to be putting our
energy thinking requires energy and when
I like to think of energy it's it's our
most valuable asset it's how we spend
how do you want to spend your energy
it's a spend like money you spend money
like time what are you spending time on
what your energy what thoughts are you
putting energy into and kind of feeding
that downward
spiral so some of the tools that I offer
uh support in pulling out of that which
takes like I mentioned acceptance of The
Human Condition and takes surrender to
what's true and a question I love asking
when a client is in this spiral they
become tortured we we do we become
tortured in this in the negative
downward spiral is have you had enough
of that and sometimes the answer is
no and like a child at nap time we have
to let it tantrum
out and that's okay
too until it Tantrums Out And what I
mean that back to what I was talking
about with energy until it loses energy
and faces entropy and it starts to just
you know you hit some kind of some
version of rock bottom of that spiral
and then I go have we had enough of
that and a client will say yeah this is
so torturous this is then we can start
working from there
so sometimes you can't just uh we're not
going to say snap out of it of course
but but sometimes just okay just accept
that it's there and we we just get it
out of our system to be able to get to a
level of being able to snap out of it
takes a lot of work and it takes a lot
of
practice just like a professional
musician who can just get on stage and
play perfectly their violin there was a
lot of work and practice that came
behind that moment so if the moment
moment is to snap out of it and get back
to work and we haven't mastered that yet
that's because there's a lot of uh
practice and preparation to do to get to
that moment
so snapping out of it is not really
important that's just a level we can get
to with a downward spiral but letting it
tantrum out and practicing the skills of
I once worked with an amazing Fitness
coach actually and he was so deep and
one of the things he said and I was
getting back into shape and he kept
saying like whenever you notice you fell
off the wagon the only skill you're
practicing is to get back on the wagon
he's like I don't need you to lift
heavier next week I don't need you to
run faster next week I don't need those
are not your gains right now your gain
is oh I didn't go to the gym like I said
I would go
tomorrow oh I had a bad meal and I'm
like messing up my diet plan wake up in
the morning and have your breakfast he's
like the only skill I want you
practicing is getting back on the horse
and I did that for for a month that was
the only thing I focused on and it gets
you really far that's what gets you out
of a spiral is
realizing you don't need to be the best
by next month you don't need to produce
your magnum opus next week sometimes you
just need to remember to harness the
skill of going yeah I got off track or
yeah I went into that spiral of negative
thoughts okay time to get back on my
path what is monkey mind monkey mind is
a it's a Buddhist term that relates to
to uh it refers to the uh worry and
doubt chatter kind of the conversations
that we have in our head it's like a
voice that swings from worry to doubt to
worry to doubt and it's the Buddhist
term for our inner critic um our
negativity bias meaning we were born all
mammals are
born with what's called a negativity
bias meaning our brain is wired to scan
for danger Keeps Us Alive and so the
monkey mind is that voice that
conversation that says maybe I shouldn't
do it maybe I'm not good enough maybe I
don't have what it takes mom and dad
want approve whatever right it's that
voice you should be an accountant you
went to school for this you should be
doing the shs the worry the doubt that's
monkey mind it's just talking to us all
day and we want to know how to turn the
dial down on that radio station it's not
going to go away this is how we are
designed but we are able to manage it
and turn the volume down on that and be
like okay thanks for sharing anyway what
is it that I'm here to
do oh I'm really curious I want to
produce this film lowbudget I'm really
curious who I could collaborate with you
know and as you step up to your goal
that monkey mind will kind of swing in
again because there's something valuable
on the other end and there's a risk
between here and there and monkey mind's
like I shouldn't do it you have a low
budget no one's going to watch it you
know what I mean like whatever it's
saying that's what monkey mind is and
most 100% of the time it's really not
telling us anything valuable or Worthy
of our
attention